voilà le massacre de masse a que deux
chiens la scène fait froid dans le dos
six moutons de chèvres et 33 poule et
massacré tuées par des chiens et rond
qui se sont introduits dans cette ferme
ces animaux appartenaient un couple
d'agriculteurs retraités
tam a dû couper le cou je peux parler et
j'ai pleuré comme une madeleine coup
j'ai pleuré comme une madeleine
j'ai plus de bêtes s'étaient je me
levais la nuit pour voir si elles
faisaient le petit après je donnais les
biberons ça touche tout ça j'ai plus
rien la taxe est déroulée dans la nuit
de dimanche à lundi alors que le couple
était absent c'est on rentre on que la
famille a découvert le carnage plus gros
que je dis c'est préjudice moral c'est
bête c'est leur vie c'est la raison
d'être tous les matins tous les soirs et
aujourd'hui plus rien et ça c'est
inadmissible
les deux chiens en cause aurait échappé
à la vigilance de leurs propriétaires où
ça une habitante du village à qui le
maire demande aujourd'hui des comptes
cette dame c'est ils sont dangereux doit
les déclarer la mairie donc elle n'a
rien fait et aujourd'hui il manque un
chien la maison où il est et ça on veut
le retrouver
parce que c'est c'est quand même
inadmissible un jour on va trouver un
gamin qui va être complètement dévorer
long de la route alors je pense que
j'aurais vraiment ça ça moi le coupable
le maire de chiffres qui a donné 48
heures aux propriétaires des chiens pour
fournir une expertise vétérinaire
évaluant la dangerosité des animaux